I'm 29 years old everybody welcome to
you laughs you lose let's freakin do
this guys accept this challenge by
smashing like on smashing like on this
video right freaking now if you're up
with unless you're right
coward I'm not afraid give me my life
points let the games begin
Hey look at that a tick-tock video don't
scroll on me okay like just listen I
want to let you know if you don't think
you're beautiful fine I don't even care
that was amazing very creative but it
will not happen again mark my words
yeah you don't don't scroll on me okay
like just listen I want to let you know
that if you don't think of you wait wait
what is this thing this is like a
breakup and you were just someone to
make bets about didn't care I wanted you
to talk to me the next day okay
I'm awful to hear that a girl is
interested in you I'm not off for a good
start Emily it's okay I got a few
sleeves up my neck this is the second
most savage thing you can send to a
breakup text just noted movie it has
been delayed 10 minutes already called
the cops you still there
what do you want no some fire music man
even crackhead know that the dankest
means
have you seen Armand Christophe don't
worry we'll get him can I help you
we'll get him we'll get up one day after
we enjoyed this wonderful band i freakin
love oblivion guys you guys if you guys
have not subscribed to bake and
underscore i don't know what to tell you
me hey you can summon from another
capri-sun Oh
careful what you wish for
mmm this is a meme that is a lesson to
learn for everyone you may think you
want a capri-sun
but do you really
goddamn that was that was hard
I'm not gonna like that was so freakin
hard but I pulled through and I made it
are you still in the game boys we did it
racism is no more hello skipper mr.
Obama very de
I came to thank you for your great
service to this country
no thanks necessary mr. Obama as a token
of my gratitude I'd like to give you the
n-word pass mr. Obama it is an honor to
call you no no no no
moving on everybody this is going great
I'm still alive still kicking it it's
incredible have I never lost one of
these I never lost your life you lose
you keep losing them all the time
[Music]
okay moving on
we'll each need to take down about ten
still you're here it's now or never we
win this I know we will
Oh boom guy I haven't seen him in years
the hand that smash
[Music]
oh yeah screw your markiplier
instead we're gonna make it
come on t-series
yeah damn it damn it how could I miss
one it's okay it's okay it's okay all
right
everyone's gonna die it doesn't matter
t-series will die - oh no t-series isn't
a physical being it's a corporate entity
that I could technically live on forever
oh god oh god damn it
Joe it becomes the stripper very nice
good mean good old classic man I need to
be more videos with the yar they're so
funny
[Music]
come on yes there's a beautiful laugh
there's no way you can come on you there
stop where your state on the rocks I
don't think you can say oh stop it
Freeman Oh Freeman please oh please
know what I'm saying
he dies anyway it doesn't matter stop
crying it's okay it's a video game
it's a video game God ants aren't real
Jesus Christ pickup pancake oh my god go
get it
weapon Dickie rice it even sweet
slippery ice it's so nice I can pick up
a mess using my pinky name is whisper
quiet and super ground furniture quick
and easy with no cords and more
batteries the strange triple brush
technology that uses sense I can pick up
right with the rotating action to sweep
up everything in its path just fresh to
empty in the trash real things mandatory
mix and the spin room has a megamouth
it's big enough pick up a ham sandwich
joint corner brushes clean along
baseboards and toe kicks with even vinyl
it gets into the grout lines leaving
nothing behind enough easily and it's
strong enough to pick up pancake
honey I think it's safe to say I lost I
definitely longer please Brad summer
please can I get another laughs thank
you catcher looks like I'm still in the
game ha ha 6 is 12 or simply 6 at of
trembler 6 is 12
well it all depends on how you look at
it because from another perspective it's
12 and from another perspective are
tough do you understand
is it like paint right Iria and the
fundamentals you have as a person
determine if it is ha the criteria or
the fundamentals as a person will affect
the answer of this mathematical question
absolutely
who is this Italian animator that didn't
always do these amazing ones I want to
know the source for the sorcerer oh
that's great okay let's look at the
result
Wow it looks like I beat you again how
about that now you have to smash like
subscribe and hit the bell button that
was there for me for now I hope you guys
enjoyed this video Scott oh you live a
comedy view Scott a little comment if
you Laura and I'll see you guys next
week goodbye